[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour ma retraite gérée et vu que vous
pouvez la lettre la peine tout les tous
les deux d'être venus c'est par une
émotion que commence cette journée de
visite de l'hôpital de yum l'association
médecins de l'océan indien a développé
une énorme logistique cette semaine pour
cette population du sud malgache
dix-sept mois qu hugo et voir c'est
mieux comprendre c'est aussi pouvoir
mieux le défendre mieux défendre les
médecins de ces indiens et puis mettre
la réunion au sein d'une solidarité mais
que c'est une âme qui coûtera non on la
perd à chaque match mais pas comme ça je
crois je prenne encore 3 lauper donc
le total est ordinaire
parce que des joueurs on l'espère cas au
moins 10 les journées sont pleines pour
ces spécialistes de l'humanitaire
médicales venues de métropole et de la
réunion on rentre en métropole ce qui
est le plus dur c'est de reprendre ce
que l'on a fait et de voir qu'on aurait
pu faire en métropole et qu'on ne peut
pas faire ici on laisse des gens on sait
que ça va mal se passer mais que s'il
avait été en métropole acculé soigner
par rapport à cliquer ici on a on a fait
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de types de
maladies katana c'est à dire les malades
difficiles
il ya beaucoup ici des maladies
parasitaires l'organisation en formule 1
les équipes sont rodées logistique
export
[Musique]
je suis pas seul
nous sommes trois logisticiens il ya un
cas actuellement qui est en brousse et
le deuxième qui est ici avec moi et
voilà et toute la journée on passe dans
les différents bureaux tu as besoin de
croire quelque chose alors ça peut aller
d'aller acheter des tales pile on
revient ben voilà le bistouri électrique
étant pas il faut trouver un mécano
enfin voilà c'est tout il pour que que
ça fonctionne
à jour s'est passée la vraie lune
propose courant à l'hôpital et du coup
quand c'est comme ça il ya des groupes
électrogènes qui sont prévus donc il
faut les appeler directement pour qu'ils
réalisent entre le bloc les visites des
salles s'enchaînent et la variété des
interventions impressionne cette mission
est attendu par cette population démunie
qui peut difficilement accéder aux soins
je sais pas besoin de voir ça je ne sais
pas quoi répondre
certainement qu'à la réunion il ya quand
même beaucoup de possibilités qui lie à
issy et malheureusement je crois que mes
amis réunionnais se plaignent parfois un
petit peu
alors qu'ils sont déjà pourvus
c'est tout ce que je peux dire beaucoup
de malgaches sont très pauvres et n'ont
pas assez d'argent pour se soigner quand
on dit aux gens qu'il faut laisser
opérer la plupart ne peut pas être
opérée depuis la loco de l'opération des
médicaments les actes opératoires c'est
un peu plus loin ces médecins malgaches
de tananarive consulte depuis la
première heure ces missions sont une
réelle opportunité c'est pas ça si tu
vois la commune d'être collectivités
président bien évidemment j'ai jamais
été à l'étranger en france
je connais que partage et de culture
leur ressenti entre ressenti c'est assez
différent et soir il ya 18h30 un médecin
dans sa spécialité fait un court dans
tous ses collègues et pour tous les gens
qui veulent participer que ce soit des
fois où l'on voyait des écoles
d'infirmières boîte là ces gens là bien
on a évolué vos lié avec dexter
expérience énorme avec les aînés et les
et les mettre à
je vais pas aller au travail
[Musique]
je
nous reprenons la route
[Musique]
comme tous les centres itinérant
l'hôpital public de re à nuire est plein
ils espèrent tous avoir une place les
bouches
c'est beaucoup mieux on a beaucoup moins
de chico bon il a toujours eu c'est
dramatique pour certains cas mais il ya
beaucoup moins il ya qu'à voir cette
affiche est là elle a toutes ses dents
avec pékin
[Musique]
la chirurgie border ont fait
pratiquement toutes ont créé des soins
on traite des carry on fait de la
prothèse amovible
on fait des extractions on fait aussi
de la protège de la prophylaxie humaine
dans la région des cars points de vie
gene de caudan terre dans cet hôpital de
mousse toutes les salles sont également
plein pourtant c'est le silence qui
impressionne ils sont malades ils ont
faim et ils patientent
c'est ce que je rapporte à la réunion
jeunes la maison fait aux jeunes un
bruit une plainte au il ya beaucoup d
enfants qui sont atteints de la
malnutrition mais mais mais aussi chez
les mères allaitantes et femmes
enceintes
du coup on fait également à part la
chirurgie ambulatoire la prise en charge
de la malnutrition avec elle et
compléments alimentaires qu'on en a la
mission des années d'efforts collectifs
avec les autorités malgaches qui portent
leurs fruits
alors pourquoi le département de la
réunion accompagne financièrement le co
développement de ce territoire
il n'y a aucune raison des différends à
cette misère ça concerne le réunionnais
en tant qu'être humain et le jour les
êtres humains seront conscients qu'ils
sont en même temps responsable de ceux
qui sont à côté qui sont défavorisés
je pense que les valises et enfin pas
énorme et ça c'est un deal au qu'il faut
tenir aux réunionnais moyens qui
s'imaginaient effectivement nous avons
des f nous avons des pauvres mais ça ne
justifie pas pour rien au monde qu'on
puisse pas s'occuper des gens de l'autre
côté qui sont la justice iations plus
désespérée
des milliers de personnes sont ainsi
soigner ponctuellement parfois a sauvé
par cette mission médicale
mais tout ça pourquoi ils sont là en une
heure et demie d'avion vous avez vous
avez vous avez ce qu'on pourrait voir
peut-être à la réunion dans les années
1900 regardez ces images et soyez
sensible fille de découvrir des gens
simples qui n'ont rien que qui ont
toujours le sourire qui se plaignent pas
je souhaite vraiment à tout le monde de
pouvoir vivre ce genre d'expérience
parce que nous vivons sur la même
planète nous vivons dans l'océan indien
et nous sommes frères et soeurs je
précise que la première femme
réunionnaise est la première maman
réunionnaise et une malgache ont donc au
moins deux pour le devoir de celle qui
nous a construit et fait ce qu'on est